kansas city chiefs if you haven't heard
won super bowl 54 and the tradition has
been although that may be changing for
the foreseeable future to have a
gigantic parade with tens if not
hundreds of thousands of people present
in the city
where the super bowl champion resides
well it happened in kansas city this
year not in san francisco and there was
an item yesterday in the wall street
journal and i hadn't thought about this
but it's very eye opening and it's
actually
quite sensible because the coronavirus
was beginning to show up in the bay area
at the same time the chiefs beat the
49ers in the super bowl by blowing the
10-point lead in the fourth quarter and
not winning the super bowl there wasn't
a parade in san francisco the hundreds
of thousands of people who would have
been pressed together in tight spaces in
san francisco
weren't there
and it kept the virus from spreading the
way that it could have and saved lives
it's a very simple chain of logic
apparently there was some big event in
philadelphia during the spanish flu and
that ended up being
a a tremendous
opportunity for the virus to spread then
and uh it makes sense so you know the
49ers lost but san francisco won because
they didn't have that giant parade right
at a very sensitive time in the spread
of the virus throughout the bay area
it's the ultimate spin zone uh the
question though is should we be saying
that the 49ers saved lives or patrick
mahomes save lives so patrick mahomes is
the one who actually saved lives in
different city and i actually had i i
wrote about this yesterday but the
ultimate spin zone is the the chicago
bears saved the most lives by not
drafting patrick mahomes and drafting
mitch trubisky instead and therefore
making sure that we never ever celebrate
anything
ever
ever again
um but but there is no there is no spin
i i understand that that's part of your
shtick it's all coincidence nobody could
have known ahead of time no no it's not
the truth yeah but it really it really
it's just a fascinating flip of the coin
happenstance right the 49ers had that
game won they win that game they have
that parade it's a far different outlook
over the past uh uh you know
eight weeks than than we would have had
if you had all those people clustered
together in san francisco for that
parade and all we all would have been
oblivious to it at the time we would
have looked back to it like we're
looking back at mardi gras as the the
origination point for what has become a
very bad development and a hot spot and
you know way too many illnesses and
deaths from the virus that was spread
because of mardi gras and we just didn't
know it was it was during that time
that we were all kind of oblivious to it
even though we were aware that there was
this vague threat out there no one
really woke up to it until march 11 when
they shut down the nba then all of a
sudden we became experts in the virus
and we had a different outlook on life
uh that we were all oblivious to before
that
listen if you're a 49ers fan and you're
not going around saying you know what's
more important than super bowls lives
human lives then you're not really a
49ers fan because this is basically what
you can say now for the rest of time
like yeah we didn't want to win that so
we wanted to save lives thank you world
the world should thank us for uh you
know having richard sherman get torched
in the fourth quarter and having patrick
holmes being credible and missing
emmanuel sanders on that bomb that is
the long play by the 49ers they should
be commended maybe the congressional
medal of honor
i i don't i don't get you sometimes this
is a real story lies no this is a real
story
it is you can always take it and turn it
into a joke i don't know
if you don't know story and you start
don't start making jokes of it then your
brain doesn't work anymore that means
that you have to succumb to just like
not you know being able to have a little
bit of fun every now and then
i i know how to have fun i have fun
you have fun at my expense you have fun
at my expense when you're on the show i
indulge your fun i facilitate your fun i
know what you're gonna say i know what
you're gonna do i know what you're gonna
tweet i know all the tweets you're gonna
like and retweet from all the people who
are saying big cat dunking on florio
again oh you saw the shaft oh i knew
that one would make you mad
i knew that doesn't make me mad it
doesn't make me mad you know what if it
if it made me mad you wouldn't be on the
show do you not understand that i have
some degree of control over who's on the
show i fought for you to be on the show
i could very easily fight for you to be
off the show so watch it
it's a good point all right i'll take
that point point point florio
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports